je regrette d'avoir quitté l'on a non
pas du tout est assez d'arbres occupé
papa jusqu'à sa majorité
il est encore allé traîner dans la forêt
et la profane c'est son travail monsieur
donnelly c'est dangereux pour lui et
surtout pour le petit il veut nous
essayer c'est tout
je fais mon boulot rend les gens nerveux
tout savoir là ils pensent que la forêt
que vous êtes en train de piétiner
appartient aux vénérables ont fait
d'érable fait sorcière voleurs d'enfants
et ses croyances ou de partager ici
c'est comme à l'ordre monsieur richess
ça bouge pas mal la nuit c'est qu'un
mauvais rêve
reste la verrouiller la porte
à temps
jeudi à toulouse derrière
si vous violez leurs terres et violon la
vôtre
vous n'auriez jamais de venir ici